[Music]
since I started writing about and
researching emotional intelligence and
business I found that the data and
support of it has only got gotten
stronger I saw recently a study this
surprised me
engineers software coders and so on were
asked were evaluated by their peers
people who work with them day and today
on how successful they were at what they
do this is turns out to be one of the
strongest predictors of success in any
field and that was correlated with their
IQ on one hand and their emotional
intelligence on the other and when I say
emotional intelligence they were
evaluated on a 360 that looks at all 12
of the key emotional intelligence
competencies and the distinguished star
performers from average the the surprise
was this IQ correlated 0-0 with their
success as rated by peers emotional
intelligence correlated very very highly
well why would that be well consider
this in order to be an engineer you have
to have an IQ about a standard deviation
or more above average that's an IQ of
about 115 or so and another recent paper
shows that there's no relationship
between career success and IQ above 120
the reason is this there is a strong
floor effect for IQ in any role all
engineers have an IQ of 115 or more so
the range of variance is very reduced
for IQ and success emotional
intelligence however varies radically so
emotional intelligence means how well
you manage yourself can you work toward
your goals despite the obstacles do you
give up too soon do you have a negative
outlook or a positive outlook these are
all emotional intelligence competencies
that matter for success
then there's the relationship
competencies can you tune into other
people do you notice other people
I remember hearing about two MIT grads
who went into a giant tech company one
of them
went around to other members of her team
and asked what are you doing how can I
help the other stayed in his office and
wrote code all day and it's very clear
who was going to get ahead it was the
one who wanted to be a team player
you don't write code in isolation
anymore everyone works on projects
together you may write the code but you
have to coordinate you have to influence
you have to persuade you have to be a
good team member
all of those are emotional intelligence
competencies that distinguish
outstanding from average performers so
when you think about it that way it
makes sense that even among engineers
emotional intelligence will predict who
is a star and who's just mediocre and
when you think about this at the
organizational level it means you want
to be sure to include emotional
intelligence when you consider hiring
people I have a friend that an executive
recruiting company specializes in
c-level hires CEOs CFOs and so on and
they once did a study internally of
people they had recommended who turned
out to be bad and were so bad they were
fired so these were failures they were
surprised to have failures but they
realized when they looked more carefully
that these were people who were hired
because of business expertise and IQ and
fired because of a deficiency in
emotional intelligence so it's more
important than ever these days and so in
hiring needs to be considered in
promoting people of course it needs to
be considered and it should be part of
HR it should be what you help people
develop further strengthen because the
good news about emotional intelligence
is it's learned and learn about and you
can upgrade it at any point in life if
you're motivated
[Music]